o
[Música]
Olá meu nome é João Pedro e eu venho
falar sobre a nova fronteira da educação
a realidade virtual só para entender
essa tecnologia a gente precisa entender
um pouquinho do passado dela e para a
gente realmente entender onde estamos
agora e para onde a gente tirar Para o
Futuro Ah pois bem a realidade virtual
Ela não é uma tecnologia nova é o
começou em 1838 control Switch som
quando ele criou o óculos
estereoscópicos que são óculos 3D
anguladas e é uma tecnologia que
basicamente ela passou por várias
alterações o que a gente tem agora
é de 1838 só para você ter uma ideia
para 1960 engenheiros da Philco não é
criar um projeto chamado headset quer um
projeto de estímulo visual esse projeto
foi usado em missões para fazer algumas
simulações é claro que não deu muito
certo que a tecnologia era muito
limitado nessa fazendo um outro salto
para 1985 dois funcionários da à tarde
sairão da empresa e criar avpl mcert
empresa que inclusive criou né cunhou o
nome realidade virtual e tentou
comercializar em grande escala produtos
não é para um uso uso da indústria de
modo geral a ver pedra unisert criou
inclusive um um
traje cheio de sensores acoplado amanhã
a um reset de realidade virtual né é
basicamente isso aqui e a NASA utilizou
em 1990 com o projeto chamado vivo quer
um projeto para a simulação de missões
espaciais e Ah pois bem de 1990 para cá
muita coisa mudou o smartphone cresceu o
uso do Smartphone propagou de uma
maneira jamais vista antes na história
da tecnologia
o e diferentes experiências na realidade
virtual foram utilizados a partir do
smartphone E é claro são experiências
não tão imersíveis Não tem aquela grande
experiência do usuário mas são
experiências bacanas foram amplamente
utilizados em diferentes setores
especialmente jogos e também um pouco na
educação né você pode ver pelo Google
cardboard e outros óculos que usam o
celular dentro você realmente consegue
extrair algumas experiências bacanas ali
só que onde estamos agora é totalmente
diferente eu falei sobre a história um
pouco Falei um pouco sobre o projeto
reto aí sobre o projeto sobre a pele
unisert falei sobre o Charleston m-1138
quando ele foi os óculos só que agora a
gente está no momento totalmente
diferente porque bem a experiência do
usuário aumento tudo extremamente
aumentou muito agora nós temos óculos
com conforto mas Além do mais nós temos
um poder de processamento jamais visto
antes
e nós temos óculos independente como
este que não precisam de não precisam de
Smartphone né não precisa de algo
externo e consegue fornecer uma
experiência amplamente imersível com
muita muita interatividade basicamente
você está fazendo parte do mundo mágico
e altamente interativo e
tem que isso quer dizer onde que estamos
agora realmente vai nos dizer onde a
gente pode chegar e na questão da
realidade virtual agora nós temos um
poder de processamento ideal na Palma
das nossas mãos onde que nem caso nós
podemos ter um entretenimento incrível
mas isso se estende Isso deve ser usado
nas escolas e nas indústrias e
treinamentos de modo geral porque é uma
outra com outro componente da educação
que temos agora totalmente diferente de
qualquer tecnologia já vista por quê é
bem agora né com novamente com esse
poder de processamento incrível nós
temos a possibilidade de trazer
simulações extremamente reais agora nós
temos a possibilidade de desenvolver
cenários para treinamentos no campo da
medicina para explorar conceitos
aprendidos em sala de aula de maneira
extremamente vida imagine você ter uma
aula sobre Vênus e você ver o planeta
Vênus e poder interagir com simulações
sobre o planeta Vênus Imagine você fazer
um treinamento Isso é verdade eu fiz
esses dias um treinamento sobre para
ressuscitação imbecis sim eu eu fiz um
treinamento sobre gestação em bebês
recém-nascidos E adivinha foi muito
bacana foi extremamente rico aprendi
muito
Oi e eu tive uma experiência maravilhosa
Oi e que eu quero dizer é que agora com
essa nova componente extremamente muito
bem utilizado na educação
abre-se um novo leque e uma e permite
uma aceleração muito acentuada do
processo de aprendizagem do aluno
E como eu posso comprar raiz são como
estudos recentes por exemplo
Universidade do Texas esse arquivos nos
Estados Unidos recentemente é indicar a
través das suas pesquisas que os alunos
tiveram aumento o extremamente
considerável do foco da memorização e da
motivação ao ter acesso a essa
tecnologia
o e outros vários estudos também
comprovam que a somente a a dimensão
espacial dentro desse mundo mágico
dentro desse mundo que o digo que é
mágico mesmo desse mundo interativo e
imersivo permite realmente não só
memorização mais a compreensão de
conceitos mais complexos e abstratos no
campo da física da química da Medicina e
por aí vai no campo da saúde é mais
ainda muito mais ainda empolgante a
gente pode ver que
diferentes né da mesma maneira que eu
fiz um um treinamento para recitação em
bebês recém-nascidos a gente pode ver
que você é de alunos da do primeiro ano
de medicina ele já podem começar a
interagir com alguns procedimentos
clínicos e cirúrgicos Ou seja a
aceleração da aprendizagem ela é
extremamente catalisada
eu já não é só acelerado é catalizado
então imagine você com metodologia ativa
você utilizando trazendo seu aluno para
prática e ainda por cima complementando
com uma tecnologia como essa é o que
Várias escolas fora do Brasil estão
fazendo e tendo excelentes resultados
Especialmente na Ásia
em alguns locais nos Estados Unidos e
alguns locais na Europa
e agora
essa tecnologia lá não é tão fácil assim
de ser implementado pessoalmente porque
a gente aqui no Brasil Ainda está
lidando com a falta de inclusão digital
realmente Ampla Ainda temos desafios
nessa área Muitas pessoas não têm acesso
à internet aí martons aos notebooks e
etc etc não tem acesso a computadores e
mesmo que tem acesso não tem o devido
treinamento isso também não se estende
para só para a população de forma geral
a gente pode lixar e a gente pode
acentuar que professores mesmo não tem
esse treinamento mas eu quero deixar bem
aqui uma reflexão muito importante que é
adoção de novas tecnologias essa do são
e prematura de tecnologias adoção está
na frente da lança está na frente do tá
na frente do evento da história frente
da revolução tecnológica permite uma uma
competitividade extremamente importante
porque como eu disse isso aqui acelera o
processo de aprendizado ser que catalisa
a e aumenta a imersão do aluno em sala
de aula e fora da sala de aula também
além de promover experiências de
entretenimento Fantástico
e eu quero deixar bem claro que por mais
que seja uma tecnologia que ainda
obviamente carece de ajustes até mesmo
no mercado brasileiro nós temos que
olhar para ela como a nova fronteira da
educação porque essa nova fronteira ela
vai chegar e a gente não pode ficar
muito atrás
e nós temos que não se posicionar e
vamos lembrar que a realidade virtual é
um novo mundo o mundo que agora passou
por ajustes e revoluções incríveis e
interações maravilhosas que nos permite
estarão em uma situação em que ela se
encontram de mais fácil acesso com mais
desenvolvimento maiores alternativas
várias empresas trazendo soluções mais
mais viáveis inclusive para o consumidor
de alto poder de imersão
Oh e vamos deixar bem claro é um novo
mundo é o mundo da realidade virtual e
Nós seres humanos somos exploradores por
natureza por definição assim que a gente
construiu a toda nossa história e mesmo
que seja o mundo virtual a gente não
pode deixar de ser explorador então eu
convido vocês eu convido todos os
educadores todos os gestores eu convido
todas as pessoas entusiastas a
tecnologia a explorarem mais a realidade
virtual porque realmente estamos num
outro patamar um outro momento e essa
revolução deve vir deve ser estruturado
aqui no Brasil obrigado